demain à versailles les grandes eaux
musicales une opération très
particulière à destination du public
pour permettre à ce site historique
s'est durement touchée par la tempête de
revivre reportages rares dalmaz michel
vasseur bassin de latone l'un des
favoris du parcours écrit par louis xiv
qui adorait ses jardins et tout leur
plaisir
le dimanche les eaux musicales au nord
l'oeuvre du souverain avec des morceaux
composés pour la cour le fief du roi
soleil c'est aussi le monde des arbres
10000 massacré par la tempête de fin
décembre
certains avaient été plantés par marie
antoinette un peu partout dans le parc
se distinguent fort bien la trouée
géante du chemin de la tornade
ce qui touche la forêt touche le fameux
chef amazonien raoni il est venu
spécialement aux jardins du roi pour y
planter un arbre originaire d amérique
très longtemps dossiers prioritaires de
versailles
la replantation dans dix ans espère ton
et le rat masqué les cats ont enlevé le
suit qui tombait le traité acheter un
nouvel arbre le transporter le planter
remettre en état le sol safin no 10
mille francs
dix mille arbres à 10000 francs 100
millions assumés par l'état le mécénat
américains surtout mais aussi les
entrées du public douze grandes eaux
musicales exceptionnelles demain samedi
un tour de clé lire la musique
s'envolent les eaux aussi que la fête
commence
si le spectacle en surface est étonnant
la cuisine souterraine ne l'est pas
moins
les douze sans jets d'eau sont alimentés
par un réseau louis 14e plomb et joie de
cuir
d'où quelques faiblesses sauf pour les
tuyaux de dernière
ce conte empire quand même
oui
il
cinquante mille entrées les jours de
grandes eaux musicales demain le roi
soleil n'aura même pas besoin de son
pouvoir absolu pour exiger la foule
patrimoine du monde
versailles blessés ne peut qu'émouvoir
le monde entier
plus